thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam nap from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more
I recently made a video about the
sideshow Bob Quran burner in Norway who
committed suicide now trt world has
alhamdulillah recently exposed the
Danish Quran burner Rasmus paludin for
sexually exploiting young boys let's
take a look at what they have found
normally
foreign
brothers and sisters not only is he
spreading hatred towards Islam and
Muslims and banning the Quran but look
at the morals of this person
he is the kind of person who would CR
who would be criticizing the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam for his
marriage to us
and this person
he has made this forum whereas guided
all of these young boys
down to the age of 13 and they would be
younger if the Discord server would
allow younger boys than that and what he
is doing on this server is that he's
abusing these young boys and making up
sexual fantasies about himself and the
boys and having making this gang rape
fantasies
let me just share with you one of the
filthy things that was reported by the
Danish media how he exploits these young
boys and honestly I don't even want to
say it because it's so dirty but just so
you understand and get the perspective
what kind of morals and person this
actually is he made up a story with one
of the young boys being dragged into his
classroom and being stripped naked and
then being raped by his teacher with an
object put into his behind trishal took
another hit as he realized he was going
to give the class the most exposed view
of his punishment Mrs ambroster ramming
the straight and hard and fast up his
he cried as he had never tried before at
the first violation of his sphincter by
the hard plastic tools
now you decide for yourself
you just think about that an individual
whose moral is that low and he's engaged
in this kind of filthy sexual
exploitation of miners who is he to even
come and criticize the Quran who is he
to come and criticize the Prophet
Muhammad sallam
he has no dignity no honor he's just a
scum of the Earth
and to be honest brothers and sisters
the only response and the only action we
need to take towards these kinds of
filthy people
this Quran burners who have no morals no
values and they only live for spreading
hatred and abusing boys
they need the guidance of Allah they
need the guidance and the purity of
Islam
if they can get the actual the true
message of the Quran and the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
they can see how pure the lifestyle as a
Muslim is then these people would not be
committing suicide
these people would not be burning the
Quran these people would be embracing
the truth of Islam
and we are establishing
a Masjid and dawah Center a Scandinavian
Masjid and dawa Center in Norway in
order to Enlighten the people about the
religion of Allah the purity of Islam
and you brothers and sisters
you are the greatest subhanallah as a
response to the Quran burning you guys
have put forward 200
000 to establish the dean of Allah and
spread the message of Islam to the
Scandinavian people brothers and sisters
let us read three hundred thousand
dollars
expand the Masjid project so we can
Enlighten the people about Islam
and if you donate towards this cause my
brothers and sisters
you would be sharing in the reward of
all of this these Quran banners and
these haters These people are abusing
children
getting the pure Message of Islam so
click the link to donate and Allah
will insha Allah build a house for you
in Paradise as promised by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
brothers and sisters let me introduce
you to Noah this is a European country
where the vast majority of people have
become irreligious there are 200 000
Muslims of a population of about 5
million and most of these 200 000
Muslims have no idea how to explain
Islam to their non-muslim friends and
neighbors what that means to change
Allah sent his Messenger to call people
to Eternal success and that is why
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
Masjid and dawah Center to enhance the
Norwegian dower but they cannot do this
alone we need to support them if you
donate to the schools you will insha
Allah reap the rewards of thousands of
Muslims coming back to Islam and many of
those will become God and invite to
Islam you will share in the reward for
all those shihadas and Good Deeds to
come inshallah so click the link and
donate now and share the video for extra
reward